e
e e
hey you know the foot first question
coming right I said I was going to
reframe the question this way how many
of you have not picked a
company I've changed the question it's
not how many you have picked a company
how many of you have not picked a
company
yet I see I I looked at the master list
this morning right so either you picked
a company and you've not entered the
master list or you
just lying right pick a company soon
pick I mean as a group if you're going
back and forth get some convergence so
you can pick a company second question
and this is I think a question that can
be useful if you're in this group I know
there's some of you who've not been able
to find a group yet so if you haven't
found a group can you put up your
hand okay so everybody's in a group this
to then in the master list is not quite
showing up because I said are you in a
group so please if you're in a group put
it down because I'd like you to get into
group and not get to week five six s and
you're still out there as a stray and I
have no idea what to do with you okay so
last session we were talking about end
games and for some of you this is a
comfortable place to be because we
haven't talked about a single number yet
that's going to change very soon so
enjoy the moment while you can
but the reason the endgame matters is
everything you do is driven by the
endgame so RI Remind Me ri right remind
me again why you can't have multiple
objectives in a
business because it's like everything
else in life you have multiple
objectives it sounds good but then you
have to make choices when I had dinner
with my youngest son who works at an
unnamed hedge fund for the moment
and he was complaining about his balance
of Life issues which is now you you work
a lot you get paid a lot the work's not
that interesting and I told him look you
got to decide what your endgame is
because as long as you say look I want
the best of everything this is exactly
the space you're going to be pick an end
game pick con straints you can't just
say I want to be happy at my work and
live in an apartment that cost $2,000
3,000 ,000 or $5,000 a month something
has to give end games Drive everything
you do and the same is true for
businesses So In traditional Corporate
Finance we start with this objective
maximize stock price and very quickly
shredded every single layer that you
need to get to that objective so we
embarked on a search can we do something
else a stock price objective function
looks pretty crappy so what about
different objective and the problem any
other objective you pick comes with the
same set of issues as stock price and
worse so maybe a different corporate
government system somebody will rescue
us somebody will take care of bad
managers and we saw that those systems
exist they're very good at dealing with
individual company problems but they
don't do very well with systematic
problems they cover them up and they
kind of
fester and almost
by you know excl tion you had to end up
back in hey there doesn't seem to be a
better way of running a
business how do we maximize stock prices
without the side costs or reducing the
the side cost will exist but how do we
minimize the side cost and we talked
about the the biggest reason why
maximizing stock prices still will
persist is it's the only self-correcting
objective because markets have no
egos you know what I mean by that right
can markets change their mind in Invidia
today yeah you can see the stock price
drop 80% overnight you can see a stock
drop it can increase markets have no
egos individuals do so if manages
overreach on the against shareholders
there is a mechanism for correction one
of those is activist investors finally
get together and say I know it's
difficult to win an annual
meeting but we're going to make it a
contest remember those proxies that get
thrown out you have a proxy contest you
and I with a th000 shares or 10,000
shares or even 100,000 shares might not
be able to pull that off but a car Ian
or a bill Amman or an Elliott can pull
that off because they can reach out to
shareholders they have their
resources and they might not change the
management but they change the way the
management thinks so if you think about
you know Disney they might have won that
contest against activist investors but
it changed the way they ran the
company and then we talked about the
right CEO for a company and I said the
right CEO for a company is going to be
different depending on where you are in
the life cycle young company requires a
very different set of skills than a
middle-age company and a middle-aged
company requires a very different set of
skills than a declining
company and towards the end of the class
we talked about how in the 20th century
that problem was taken care of by
time you just passed on so by the time
the company moved from Young to middle
age the CEO had gone from young to old
age so you got a new CEO
in but in the 21st century the template
for Success has shifted I gave you the
example of four right 120 years and time
took care of the problem let's look at
the sad but true story of Yahoo founded
in 1992 by two yahoos they call
themselves The yahoos they're basically
Stanford Engineers who dropped out
created a company it was incredibly
successful it rode the do com boom to be
worth a100 billion by
1999 what took for decades to do Yahoo
did in seven
years this is the draw that Silicon
Valley has on us right companies can get
scale up incredibly
fast in no time at
all but it comes with a consequence the
same forces that allow you to scale up
quickly which is low Capital intensity
not much stickiness in the business mean
that you can't stay at the top for very
long how long did yaho stay at the top
about four to 5 years in fact we can
date its decline to the day Google went
public so in 200 before Google comes
along and all of you know essentially
overnight Yahoo went from being the
dominant search
engine to a second place or even a third
place finisher and by 2012 Yahoo was
done as a search
engine I remember valuing yahu when
Marissa Maya came in remember the pull
of Marissa May again was she was
successful at Google and what was her
Mission when she was brought to Yahoo
make Yahoo great
again it's not going to happen I I I
remember you know looking at that
mission say this is an impossible
mission not a Tom Cruz kind of
impossible mission because he always
seems to pull it off but an impossible
mission because it's not fixable in what
universe is Yahoo going to go back to
being the dominant search engine she
tried though she bought tumbler for a
billion and thre a couple of billion but
three years later she said5 billion
down the drain she said I tried with
other people's money and by 2015 Yahoo
was
done 23 years from birth to death you
know we built business schools around
20th century companies everything we
teach including in my classes are built
around the 20th century company and I'll
give you an
example I teach valuation some of you in
my valuation class
how do we value companies somebody give
me a framework we estimate cash flows
for a period and then we stop and then
anybody want to fill in the G Kevin what
do we do at the end of year five or 10
we've estimated cash flows we're tired
of doing this so we stop and put closure
by
estimating a terminal value and how do
we estimate a terminal value we assume
cash flows continue to grow at a
constant rate for how long forever you
know why because it gives us it's a
convenient assumption right from the
beginning we've known it's unrealistic
but the reason we got away with it is
the present value of cash flows forever
is very close the present value of cash
flows over 60 or 70 years so the 20th
century company we lasted 80 90 years
hey this was
okay you already see the issues when
you're valuing a zoom I mean I'm on Zoom
right now I like Zoom do you really
think zoom's going to be around 90 years
from now forget about 90 years 10 years
from
now it's a technology it's a great
technology but it to it too shall
fade so when you value Zoom do you
really want to stop in your 10 assume
cash flows continue forever I
don't there are ways to deal with it but
so much of what you are taught in
business is built on the premise in fact
the whole notion of corporate
sustainabil is can I make Zoom look like
GE last 100 do you you really want zoom
120 years from
now I think we need to rethink some of
the things that we take for granted in
business and say given the shorter life
cycle I mean the way I described this
when I wrote about this 10 years ago
is tech companies age in dog years you
know the legend of dog years that dogs
age seven times faster a 20year tech
compan is like a 140 year old
Manufacturing
Company it's really old
so when you think about tech companies
and you look across their life cycle
Microsoft and Apple are not just old
they're like you know centuries old and
they managed to be successful but
they're the exceptions think about all
the great tech companies and many of you
don't even remember the name go back to
the 80s these are the 10 great look at
how many of them are still
around but here's the
problem time doesn't take care of your
CEO Pro so who was in charge of of Yahoo
as it became a mature company the same
people who built it up as a growth
company and they were really unable to
deal with the fact that they were a
middle-aged mature company you want
something happened in even speedier
Motion in time take a look at Blackberry
or watch the movie there's actually a
documentary series about Blackberry
remember Blackberry a Canadian tech
company that's kind of an oxymoron but
let's go with it no I mean I can think
of shopu fire and blackberry came out of
nowhere and by the end of the 90s it was
the I mean people developed Blackberry
thumb because they was so busy texting
with you could text everybody had a
Blackberry dominated the business at
least the business phone
market then what happened the iPhone
came along
smartphones and the people who viewed
his Geniuses for building Blackberry
remained in place as Blackberry went
from you know worth be worth billions to
nothing and they did exactly what they
did when was a successful Growth Company
that's part of the prom they were
incapable of adapting so time's not
going to take over the problem so if you
think in corporate governance terms we
need to have the power to change CEOs
more than ever before because the kinds
of companies that were surrounded
by and at exactly the time when we need
that power the most we seem to have
disarmed
ourselves by creating companies where
it's difficult to create
change Facebook slm
right the young company I mean clearly
it's dominant right now will it be
dominant for the next Century I don't
think so it to shall pass but with
Facebook what do we allow it to do we
allowed it to issue two class of shares
and you got to blame Google for this
Google opened the door to two class of
shares now Facebook walked in and in
Facebook if you look at the shareholding
there's Class A shares and Class B
shares and you don't need to be a
business person even to know who
controls the voting shares now
Zuckerberg owns 13.5% of the total
outstanding shares but he controls 57%
of the Voting
Rights this is Zuckerberg's company you
can take a look at Google you'd see the
same thing and there's a whole set of
tech companies who have allowed this to
happen what does that mean there will be
a time at these tech companies we say I
don't like the way this company is
managed and there's nothing you're going
to be able to do about it it's a
terrifying idea the century where we
need corporate governance the most being
able to hold managers accountable we've
essentially created companies where we
have benign dictators running these
companies for the
moment but what happens if they become
malignant
yes F Duty does the founder or anything
have to the rest of the shareholders
even if they don't have voting right
well let's start with what they cannot
do they cannot do things that obviously
transfer wealth from the you know
because then you can sue and say that
but let's suppose you want to do an
acquisition right remember this isn't
outright fraud we're talking about about
decisions that insiders make that they
feel is the best interest of the
company and remember they have more to
lose than you and I so they're not this
isn't the traditional conflict of
interest between managers and
shareholders they're not thinking like
managers they're thinking like this is
my company this is my baby I want to
make it work but their decisions might
not be the decisions you make as an
outside investor let's start with one
fundamental problem today we're going to
talk about how outside investors think
about risk they think about risk as risk
added to a
portfolio what's Zuckerberg biggest
investment in his portfolio see so he's
going to kind of when he looks at risk
look at it very differently than the
rest of the world so this isn't about
bad guys and good guys again this is
about conflicts of interest initially
when things are great you don't notice
these conflix but it's when things start
to go I mean let's face it he probably
thought the metaverse was a great idea
and you got to give him credit he listen
to the market why because his market cap
was melting down just as much as
everybody else not all CEOs are that
attentive to the market so with every
one of these conflicts played out are
there going to be places where the
decisions made by the CEO are going to
be decisions that the rest of the
shareholders agree with and if they
don't this case there's not much you can
do about
it take the second linkage remember in
traditional theory you lend money to a
firm you didn't protect yourself you got
Nabisco
now what can you do about it too late on
the Nabisco thing and I talked about
some of the things that happened after
Nabisco because Bond holders had been
hurt one of the things you noticed is
bonds started to get
reframed with protections put in talked
about putable bonds we could take a bond
and put it back to the company saying
you've changed the terms of this
agreement you did an lbo I assumed you
were a safe company and this is a very
different company give me my my my face
value back the $1,000 back if the
Nabisco bonds had been putable you
wouldn't have seen the 20% drop right
because they have put the bonds back got
their money back you could also have in
Maryland became very inventive in the
late 80s they issued bonds with where
the in a regular Bond the coupon rate is
set up front it's fixed for the life
meril issued bonds called rating
sensitive bonds where the coupon rate
would actually adjust if your r in
dropped dramatically so you went from
double A to Double B the coupon rate go
from 7% to 12% to fully compensate you
for the risk you
to it's a pain when you create these
complex bonds to price them you don't
want to do it unless you have to but you
start to see that happen the second is
you also saw bonds with more Equity
components them more convertible Bond
issues he's saying how does that protect
me as a bond H who's ripping you off the
equity investors right so what do you do
if you rip me off too much I'll become
one of you and then who do you have to
rip off it's a natural way in which you
bring in your protection that's why if
you're a VC for God's sakes never lend
money on a fixed interest rate to a
young
company always have an equity component
because without the upside the equity
investors will take advantage of you so
you saw this happen again too late to
protect the Nabisco Bond holders but it
was a Market's way of saying we're going
to learn from this
mistake financial markets we've done
this dance all through this class about
markets and efficiency but you got to
live in the world you're in markets are
there you got to reveal information them
we talked about how companies play the
information game delaying news sometimes
lying about what's happening and markets
are not always cool and rational this is
what the system brings in as the as the
blowback on both those Dimensions if you
lie to
Market eventually the truth comes out
when the truth comes out what happens
your stock price drops and it stays down
why because you've lost all
credibility who's going to believe you
from this day
on I'm not going to condone mature
companies lying to markets but at least
I can see the gaming there I've never
understood young growth companies go out
and lie to markets why because much of
your values in your growth assets right
and it's all built on expectations which
are driven by
credibility Groupon very early in its
corporate life played stupid games on
earnings trying to make their earnings 5
cents higher and I looking so why would
you do that you're a company where 80%
of your value is expectations you're
going out there and messing with that
for a 5cent increase in earnings per
share and if you delay news markets have
their own way of reacting to it in that
paper that I showed you about what
happens by weekday and earnings reports
I also looked at what happens when
earnings announc earnings reports are
delayed relative to when you'd expect
them to most companies actually report
earnings on roughly the same day every
year if it's a weekend they might be you
know doing a day but if it's on February
18th and that's when Nidia reports
earnings that's around let's say
February 18th comes along the company
says we're not reporting earnings
yet 19th comes around 20th comes around
what's happening do you think in the
market you sitting back and say oh
that's okay when earnings reports are
delayed the stock price starts to drop
because you assume that no news is more
likely to be bad
news markets basically have to do their
best so when you delay news you could
actually be undercutting yourself
because markets might assume the worst
and and all you might have is just a
little bad news I actually think it's
better in the world we live in to
actually go out and Report the news
because guess what not only do Market do
it but somebody on Twitter in your
company is probably going to reveal the
bad
news either intentionally or by accident
it's going to come out anywh might as
well get ahead of the game and put your
own spin on your bad
news and when markets
overreact guess who feels the pain those
investors overreacted because they sold
too low they bought too high i' I I feel
very little sympathy for people who make
you know when you make mistakes in
markets you have to bear the con that's
the essence of risk it's not the
government's job it's not the
regulator's job to come in and protect
you so in both cases there is enough of
built into the mechanism to keep you on
track which brings us to the last and
perhaps the thorniest of the four
linkages
again we talked about how with ESG and
sustainability we're trying to keep
companies from not doing bad things and
I'm with you on that Dimension I don't
think companies do do bad things but
just telling companies don't do bad
things it's not going to work especially
if the bad thing you're doing is still
legal but there is a consequence of
walking too close the line as a company
right you do what's legal and you
basically say it's legal I'm going to do
it because it's
legal and you're framing a story that's
not a very palatable story for society
it talked about the Valiant you know the
Canadian farmer
company eventually that story is going
to lead you to either step over the line
because you're walking too close line in
which case you have a blowback blowb
from what your customers stop buying
your product government stop having
contracts with you I mean on mobile
after their Valdes oil spill it took
them a decade to get back contracts
British Petroleum after deep water still
struggling even though those might be
because there but for the grace of God
does goes every other Oil Company right
it wasn't that they were particularly
bad but you're in a business where
you're doing things that are legal but
effectively creating this cost if
there's a catastrophe I think it's
actually makes good Financial sense to
think about catastrophic risk and say
what what can we do to reduce the chance
if you're an oil company you want to
create at least enough safety mechanisms
that you're less likely to be the next
BP or the next Exon because you have an
accident but I think there are limits to
what you can effectively do in this it's
a
constraint but it's not a binding
constraint not all companies will feel
it so here's the consequence if you're
one of those companies that keeps those
constraints in your decision maker and
your competing against other companies
in your group that are
unconstrained there will be times when
those companies are going to look much
better than you and you have to be okay
with it because you're maximizing value
in the long term and that requires
reducing your catastrophic
risk I mean if you were reframing ESG as
something or sustainab is something that
is actually know compatible with
corporate finance I would reframe it as
don't be bad forget about the big good
part don't be bad
if you can just do
that much of what we worry about in
society will go away don't tell me
you're doing good stuff on the side and
things that don't even match up to your
business that's not where the pay the
payoff for society or business is going
to be just don't be bad so ultimately I
call this constrained corporatism so if
you get a chance compare all of the
different corporatism starting with
Robert Baron corporatism which is what
we started with the Andrew Carnegie you
know you know and all the different
dimensions this is where I've ended up
where essentially you have a job as a
manager in a company you got to keep all
of these different stakeholder groups
reasonably happy but you have a single
stakeholder group that ultimately you
answer to which is
shareholders and when they say why do
you go out and make more money you got
to at least be able to explain to them
why you're not doing things that are
legal but could potentially create risks
for you
and frame it it's your job as managers
to frame it in terms of this is why
we're we're adopting these constraints
because we think it's good for value and
you got to be tangible about what those
benefits are and not
overreach so let's sum up where we are
you want an endgame you tell me what
kind of company you are and what kind of
Market you operate in I can at least
start framing your choices if you're a
company in a reasonably efficient market
what does that mean 95% of the time the
market makes mistakes but they're random
they cut both ways they're not
systematic mistakes then I say just
maximize stock prices and make sure the
Contra contractual structures that are
in there and this is really the
government's job right ensure that the
contractual structures regulatory job
contractual structures there to go out
and make sure you're not taking
advantage of St stakeholders if you're a
publicly traded firm in an inefficient
Market I think it's extraordinarily
dangerous to focus on maximizing stock
prices why because markets might be
rewarding you for all the wrong things
and you're going to build a bad business
because they're rewarding you we saw
this with tech companies in the last
decade right the market there were VC
investors what were the rewarding tech
companies for doing scaling up more
users great even more users even
better and if you cater to that you
build really monstrously B big scaled up
companies with terrible business
models and we're going to spend this
decade unraveling some of those
companies because those bad business
models can't be
sustained so there you might want to
maximize value which means thinking
about how do I build a business model
for the long term that creates value
that goes beyond number of
users the companies that did that will
be the survivors one re one thing that I
give Facebook credit for
is Mark Zuckerberg never really made it
all about users his objective was how do
I monetize users you might not like him
for that but he effectively understood
that you don't build businesses on
numbers of users you got to make money
of those users if you're in a publicly
traded firm and bond holders are not
fully
protected you can wait for them to get
the Protections in place but my guess is
that if you want to be a long-term
player in this you don't want to rip off
Bond holders because you got to go back
in there so even if there are
loopholes try not to exploit them and
you really have to try because he's
saying they've left me this loophole
because there's a reputation effectory
whatever he's saying what about if
you're a private company you don't have
stock prices to maximize but you still
have
value everything in corporate finance
still holds you just don't have this
feedback mechanism from the market
Market saying you did the right thing or
you did the wrong thing it's much more
difficult as a consequence to run a
private business because you don't get
that feedback that's why I said you
don't realize how much we use market
prices until I take it away so when a
public company goes private it's
actually much more difficult to run that
company because you don't get the
instant feedback from the market so I'm
going to let you kind of work through
that because as I said I've been pretty
black and white about what I think about
good objectives and bad because I need a
central end game and I've picked mine
I'm not going to force my end game on
yours but if you pick a different end
game here's what I want you to be okay
with as we go through this class when I
come up with this is the best way to
pick a project this is the best metric
you can use it's based on my endgame
which is maximizing value if you have a
different endgame and you disagree with
that Ma the way I'm picking projects
it's not because you don't like that
approach but because you have a
different end
end games Drive disagreements about what
business should do and we need to get it
on the table and talk about the end game
rather than make this a fight about npv
versus return on capital or npv versus
something else because that's not where
you really have a disagreement so any
questions on on end
games if you have I didn't put it up
there but if you have a nonprofit as
Corporate Finance apply to you well it's
not not maximizing value obviously
that's not where you there it's some
other Mission you have and you got to be
clear about what that mission is right
so if you're a nonprofit Hospital what
exactly is your endgame and don't say
it's to provide quality Health Care to
all because you'll have to face choices
be more specific about what you mean by
Healthcare what's quality to whom
because you're going to have to dance
this dance in the future because you
insurance covering some people uninsured
people walking in and your mission will
determine where you end up in that
process so now let's start on the
discussion of the meat and potatoes so
we're going to talk about the hurdle
rate let me reframe the restate the
object the the the first principle the
hurdle rate should reflect the riskiness
of what you invest in and should also
reflect the mix of debt and Equity that
used to fund that
investment so what I'd like to start
with is the notion of a hurdle
rate why do we need a hurdle rate
because you have to decide what return
you need to make on something before you
can decide whether the investment is
good or bad so at the at the risk of
being simplistic a hurdle rate is
basically going to start with what can I
make on a guaranteed investment so when
we talk about riskless rates this is not
an abstraction if you don't know what
you can make on a guaranteed investment
the rest of business becomes kind of
amorphous
you might say I know that already well
that riskless rate can be tricky to
estimate in some currencies easier and
others so we you know that's the
starting point and then you're going to
add a risk premium that should reflect
how much risk you see in the investment
and what kind of Premium demand already
you can see the two questions we got to
start with one is what is risk how do we
measure it we're going to start with
that question and second how do we
convert that risk measure into number
right because if I just say higher risk
investment to have higher risk premiums
that's not enough you have to say how
much are 5% 7% so let's start with the
first question which is what is risk
right so I want somebody here to help me
out on on risk because you've taken a
foundations class some of you might have
actually taken Finance in your
undergraduate
classes what is
risk anybody want to give me a working
what is
risk let's be honest there when you
think about risk because you've said
about upside and downside right do any
of you lie awake at night worrying about
upside risk all right so already you can
see this definition of risk which comes
from Finance classes which is now it
cuts against your intuition which is why
am i c upside upside is good it's
downside but you're right we Define it
as no as but when you say deviation of
of returns what does that actually mean
that but but know first we need to
Define risk are we defining risk as you
know the actual returns you're going to
make on something are different from
your expected return both directions so
and we'll come back and talk about why
we do that not just focus on downside
risk but I'm glad you didn't say
uncertainty were you going to say
uncertainty
sh I would just thisis is the
probability of success and failure on a
given you
know you know what economists have
danced this dance about the difference
between uncertainty and risk I've never
understood I've read all the literature
this goes back 100 years now but
uncertainty in Risk now this is two
words both of which are nebulous and the
problem is after you've taken a finance
class we think of it in statistical
terms because what you just describe
statistically what do we call that the
standard deviation and
variance I think we've ruined the way we
think about risk and finance by making
it statistical I know the the desire to
make it St you need a number but the
truth is risk is that feeling in the pit
of your
stomach when the only stock you own it's
Nvidia you bought it two years ago or a
year ago is melting down and you're not
going to get able to get your cell order
in Risk is not a number it's that
feeling of hey the world is melting down
I'm going to give you my favorite
definition of risk and it doesn't come
from Finance it's a Chinese definition
for crisis of big risk and I'll tell you
up front I know no Chinese this could be
a gigantic hoax pulled on me could be
something obscene for all I know in fact
see those Chinese symbols you know how
many times I've had to change them
because every time I put them in my book
I get about a thousand Chinese writing
to me and the problem with the Indians
and Chinese you get a lot of people
writing no matter what it is because a
small subset of a very big population
saying that's not the right symbol and
maybe it's got something to do with
simplified Chinese and complex CH I I
give up I keep changing it I'm not going
to change it
anymore because this symbol I think
captures the essence of risk the first
part of the symbol is a symbol for
danger the second part is a symbol for
opportunity risk is danger plus
opportunity it's a perfect way to think
about risk you know why because too
often in business risk is thought off as
a bad thing and the minute you could
think of it as a bad thing what do you
do with bad things you try to make them
go away right you hedge against risk you
and I I agree that that's something that
you want to do with some risk but
clearly there are other risks you want
to seek out and exploit because you
think I have a competitive
Advantage risk is danger plus
opportunity and if you want one you got
to live with the
other oh you don't like danger don't go
looking for 30%
returns think of how many
scandals and scams in investing in
business would not exist if you remember
this
linkage I'll tell you a story anybody
here from Orange County
California no
nobody
oh way back there nice place I I drive
through Orange County all the time
because I have to go from San Diego to
LA I go to Disneyland frequently because
my son works for Disney and I get him
for free that's a big plus yeah it's one
of the wealthiest counties in the
US and about 30 plus years ago early
'90s it declared
bankruptcy you know why because the the
treasurer of the county had taken a big
chunk of the County's pension
fund and made a bet on German interest
rates I can't even make up this stuff
made a bet on German interest rates and
obviously lost the bet so 40% of the
pension fund gets wiped out obviously
this is a scan hand he's on 60 Minutes
his name is Bob
citen I think most of the people in
California have made up
names citan Orange County this sounds
like an incredible coincidence right
Citrus citen but maybe that's his real
name his name is Bob citran he's on 60
Minutes and he's being interviewed by
Mike Wallace legendary no interview hard
questions so he says M Mr citan why
would you take pen fund money that's
supposed to be invested in safe things
and invested on the speculative bet on
German interest rates and here's Bob
citran answering he says because Charlie
CL told me I could make 15% with no risk
to which your reaction is who the heck
is Charlie CL and why is he telling you
these things Charlie CL was meril
Lynch's Market strategist in the early
90s and I don't believe for a moment
that he said that you know why not
because I know Charlie but because I've
heard Market strategies any of you heard
Market strategist they're incredibly
slippery
creatures they're incapable of making a
decisive statement you ask them will the
market go up so on the one hand it could
go up on the other hand it could go down
third hand it could stay the same by the
time you come out you have no idea and
this is great for them because no matter
what happens I told you
so so but let's stay with the story
let's say Charlie claw got drunk and he
said you can make 15% no risk we're back
to the interview and Bob citen says and
I'm not a finance
person what's your job title treasurer
of the country I thought that was a
finance job but it turned out to be an
elected
job do you need to be a finance person
to know that if somebody says you can
make 15% with no risk they're
ly if you think you can make 15% no risk
you probably think that that watch you
bought on Canal
Street that the guy said was a Rolex for
$45 is really
Rolex it's not I mean it's misspelled r
o e c KS I mean you can't expect good
spelling for
for you don't get Mickey Mantle rookie
cards for $5
either but we fall for it every single
time
collectively you know the really clever
scam artists do right they make it look
like it's mildly possible that this
could happen Bernie made off
what was a sales pitch to people who
invested that you can make 8% with no
risk this is a very clever scam it's not
80% so you know 8% is higher than the 5%
T bond rate said maybe and then he gives
you I found these really clever ways of
use the word arbitrage in that because
that kind of makes your story itself of
finding and I can make it no it's turned
out to be to be false just like every
other scam
so
investing it's not that we seek our
danger for the sake of of of of being
exposed we're not bungee Jumpers in
finance we expose ourselves to Danger
the question we ask is how much
opportunity do we need to compensate for
that danger that's really the end game
in every risk and return model in
finance now we could spend a lot of time
going through risk and return models I'm
not going to do that I'm going to give
you about a 15 to 20 minute derivation
of the co the still the default model
for risk and return Finance the oldest
risk and return model in finance called
the capital asset pricing model you've
seen it in foundations probably seeing a
much better derivation I'm going to give
you a completely intuitive way of
deriving why the capm comes up with the
measures of risk that it does and then
I'm going to present the Alternatives in
30 minutes from now I'll be done with
risk and return models I'm not going to
look back I'm done the rest of the
classes we're going to apply the models
but let's start by looking at what you
want a good risk and return model in
finance to do first it has to come up
with a measure of risk that applies to
all
assets you know what I mean by all so
measure of risk you have to come up
which shouldn't just be for US Stocks it
should be for all stocks not just for
stocks but include bonds and real estate
so whatever measure of risk you have
should cut across why because as
investors we have choices
across all those asset classes second it
should clearly specify what types of
risk will get rewarded and what types of
risk will not and give you the the
rationale for why so already I'm putting
on the table that not all risk gets
rewarded so if you live across a six
Lane highway from a brokerage house and
you run across all six lanes and it's a
busy highway to get to the bro that's a
risk you're exposing yourself to but you
shouldn't get a higher expected return
for doing it the risks that will get
reward wed risk that will not model has
to specify which third it'll be nice if
the risk measure that comes up with is
standardized what does that mean if I
give you what the risk measure is I
don't need to tell you what the rest of
the world looks like to tell me whether
this is a risky investment and average
risk investment or a safe investment
it's got to stand alone makes it easier
to use fourth it should take that risk
measure and convert it into an expected
return don't forget the end game here
we're trying to come up with a hurdle
rate so what whatever we're doing here
has to turn into extra 5% extra 7% extra
9%
return and here's the final requirement
it's a bit of a pain should at least
work on some companies some of the time
preferably a lot of companies a lot of
the
time but that's the end game so I'm
going to lay out what as I said is still
the most widely used risk and return
model in the world it's called the
capital asset pricing model or the cap
app
developed in 1963 and 64 by Bill Sharp
and John litner who got Nobel prizes for
doing
it I'm going to lay out the five steps
and I'm going to go through each step
intuitively as to how you arrive at the
end model it starts by using variance so
that's how we end up with variance
starts with variance of actual returns
around an expected return file that away
for the moment because I'm going to give
you some examples of Investments and you
can see this play out so we've entered
the statistical Arena we measure risk of
returns returns in what in stock prices
already you can see the choice between
markets and looking at accounting
numbers it's going with markets we'll
talk about why that choice was made
second it specifies that only the
portion of the variant that you cannot
diversify away will get rewarded now
this is a big leap you know why because
only about 20 to 25% of the risk in a
company is risk you cannot diversify I'm
already taking the remaining 75% and
saying you're not going to get rewarded
this requires some justification we'll
talk about how the capm arrives at that
justification third it measures that
risk you cannnot diversify away with a
number it's a Greek alphabet on it why
I've never understood why we could have
picked anything we wanted but we decided
to raate the Greek alphabet and then the
option guys took over and took the rest
of the alphabet right called a
baate and aate Standalone risk measure
why because the beta for an average risk
compan is
roughly what's beta standardized
round come on foundations it's now it's
one so if I tell you the beta for a
stock is 1.5 I don't have to tell you
anything more I'm telling you based on
my analysis this stock is riskier than
the average stock in the Market at least
on non- diversifiable risk that beta
then goes into an expected return
equation we take the risk free rate we
still have talked about it a risk
premium for investing in an average risk
investment and then you scale it to the
beta so far so good right for coasting
this one small problem it doesn't work
very well we'll talk about how that's
given rise to Alternative models and why
we come back to this model and why it
doesn't work very well and how to make
it work better so let's start with the
first step in that
process the capital asset pricing model
oper Ates in What's called the mean
variance framework it's a kind of fancy
way of saying that when you're an
investor there are only two dimensions
on which you measure an investment
what's the expected return that's a mean
and what's the variance of Returns on
that
investment which is the
variance so let's think about what this
variance is it's variance of actual
returns around an expected return I'm
going to give you three maybe four
Investments and I want you to think like
an investor
about what the variance is going to mean
let's say you buy a one-year
table today you can go on the US
Treasury site and you can buy one your
TBL you don't even have to go through a
broker you can directly get I checked
this morning the rate was about
4.4% so you buy a one-year
table and tbls come with they they don't
give you a coupon it's discounted so you
earn the 4.4% you invest less than
100,000 you'll get the 100,000 back 4
.4% what let's say your time Horizon is
one year and this is going to be
critical one year from now I come and
knock on your door and ask you what you
made on the TBO assuming the US Treasury
doesn't default and we've got to make
that assumption for the moment what's
your return going to be on the
Teo exactly
4.4% exactly 4.4% there's no surprises
here your time Horizon it's a one-year
table let's stay on treasuries let's
instead of buying the one-year t-
accidentally you bought a 10year
t-bond right now the coupon rate is
4.6% you still have a one year time
Arizon one year from now I come and
knock and and say what did you make on
the t-bond what's your answer going to
be you're going to start with the
4.6% but what else do you have to worry
about it's got 9 years left right on the
bond would something happen to the price
of the bond in fact what causes the
price of know treasury bonds to change
if interest rates go up the price of the
bond will decrease if interest rates go
down it'll go up so if the price of the
bond changes you're going to have an
extra component that you have no control
over a 10-year t- bond is risky if you
have a one-ear time Horizon we're
already starting to lay the foundations
for risk free rates right to give your
risk free rate you have to specify your
time Horizon a 10 year T bond is risky
Because the actual returns are going to
be different from the expected return
you know what the
actual return on a 10e t Bond was last
year we started the year with a coupon
rate of
3.88% we ended the year with a coupon
4.58% I've given you a clue was the
actual return less than 4 3.88% or more
than
3.88% it's going to be less because the
rates go up right it was minus
1.64% you should have seen what
2022 or TW
what the number look like in 2022 in
2022 we started the year with the t-bond
rate at
1.51% we ended the year with the t-bond
3.88% you know what the return on t-
bond was that year minus 20% the worst
year in history for t-bonds so don't
anybody tell you t-bonds are riskless
because it depends on your time
Horizon so we got let's say we stay on
the T go back to the one-year table
which is risk free and let's suppose I
came to you with a stock let's make it
corad why do I pick on conned nice
regulated uity you're not going to get
too many surprises and you buy conad
because you expect to make a return of
7% you're being realistic it's a safe
stop one year from now when I knock on
your door and say what return did you
make are you going to make exactly
7% no if you're lucky you might have
made 9 10 11 maybe 15% if you're not it
could be 32 or even minus
1% actual returns are different from the
expected return riskier than the t- bond
which is riskier than the
t-u it's one final step of the ladder
finally you decide to get on the Invidia
bus you've been off the bus for so long
everybody else is making money you do it
because you think you can make a 12%
return one year from now I come and
knock on your door if you're lucky what
could have happened your stock could
have doubled right it's done it couple
of times over the last three years and
if you're not you could have lost
50% in actual
returns Invidia is riskier than ConEd
ConEd is riskier than a 10year Tor a
10-year t-bond is riskier than a t-il
with a one-year
timzer but in each of these
cases where's the risk coming from it's
coming from what could happen in the
next year right but if I ask you to tell
me how risky Nvidia is or how risky
ConEd is what are we all trying to do in
a finance class run as quickly as we can
to a Bloomberg or go online and look up
the standard deviation in Nvidia and
ConEd looking at the next year of
returns no it's looking at the past this
is a conundrum we're going to come back
to and and talk about all through this
class risk is always in the future but
all our data is in the past there's no
way around it there's no magic bullet
that I can give you and when we use past
data to measure future risk we are
making implicit assumptions and might be
better to make those implicit
assumptions
explicit and I'm going to try to force
you to do that because without it you
just make leaps of
faith we measure Returns the risk in
something with the
variance but I'm going to ask you a much
more no fundamental question in this
world as investors you pick between
expected return and and and and standard
deviation you want High expected returns
and you don't like high standard
deviation so you had to rank stocks
you're going to try to maximize expected
return given a level of risk or minimize
a standard deviation for a given level
of return only two Dimensions nice and
convenient but to see if you live in a
mean variance world you know and this
actually is we Look Backwards this is a
Disney standard Devi leading to 2013
it's not difficult to do each each month
I compute the percentage return on
Disney what is that required the price
at the start of the month the price at
the end of the month with a little
additional component thrown in in the
form of in some months what will I get
in addition to the price change if there
is a dividend there might be it so it's
not rocket science you can do this the
data is there and the numbers are all
over and you can see there's I can
compute and these numbers you just do
because that's what we're trying to do
does that mean Disney's future standard
deviation is going to no it just there's
a measure of standard deviation in the
past but this is the question I want to
ask you in this mean variance framework
we assume that that's all you care about
as investors what's he expected to do
what's a standard deviation so to see if
you live in the mean variance world I'm
going to present you with a couple of
investment choices and I want you to
tell me whether there's things beyond
the variance that might affect your
choice so here's the first one let's say
you have two in Investments that have
the same expected return and the same
standard deviation so in the mean
variance world you should be in
difference between the two but here's
one little additional piece of
information that I'm going to throw in
and I want to see if it'll alter your
decision investment a offers a very
small possibility that you could
quadruple your money that's in the
expected return already it's in the
standard deviation but there is this
very small chance investment B the
highest possible payoff you can get is
60%
so I want an honest answer from your gut
how many of you would be in the mean
variance well say that doesn't matter to
me be indiff how many of you would
prefer investment a because it allows
you to
quadruple
anybody it's called preference for
skewness that sounds like a fan but if
you play DraftKings yesterday while the
Super Bowl was on what was your expected
return
definitely negative because a house
takes some of the money but you did it
why because if you were right the payoff
would be 500% I mean you can try as hard
as you can buying stocks you're never
going to get that hit of you know I I
got that 800% return we are drawn to Big
upside and sometimes we'll accept an
investment with a lower expected return
even a negative expected return because
it gives us a chance to make 10 times
our
money would any of you prefer investment
B because it gives you I think there's a
preference of skewness that cuts across
but let's actually add another dimension
to it what if I told you that there's
only that that you could lose 100% so
this is an added component in addition
to the great upside what if I told you
there's a chance you could lose all of
your money in a and that the worst thing
worst case scenario with B is minus
50% how many of you would pick B over a
now because I I minimized your
losses and again that's a factor of risk
aversion right it's one of the question
they ask you when you go into to broker
what's the most you're willing to
lose and we have preferences we're
already off the mean variance framework
right because we've now said in addition
to the expected return and the variance
what else would you like to know what
the best possible return I can make and
what's the worst case scenario with this
investment doesn't make you irrational
in fact I would argue that's completely
rational what we're doing in risk and
return models and finances we're
ignoring it because it makes our life
difficult there are risk and return
models that try to bring them in they
become incredibly complicated very
difficult to use but you have to be
aware when we use the capm you are
operating in this
framework let's move to the Second Step
let's say you've accepted the first step
variance in spite of all your qualms
about putting it all on expected return
in
variance not all risk is created equal
when you invest in a company let's stay
with Disney right let's say you invest
in Disney it's obviously made big bets
on Disney plus the next Avengers movie
let's pick one of those let's pick the
next Avengers movie coming up there lots
of questions out for a while an Avengers
movie was slammed up with 18 Avengers
movies with a billion dollars plus and
gate
receipts it's become a little shakier
for lots of different reasons I'm not I
don't have no idea where I'm in the
Multiverse anymore who's alive who's
dead they keep coming back I'm
incredibly confused and then you've
thrown in all these series on Disney
plus which have kind of put me into
distracting
zones so now you're going to spend a
half a billion dollars which is roughly
what the budget is for an Avengers movie
with the marketing on Avengers movie is
it guaranteed to make money no maybe
it's expected to make money but if an
Avengers movie
fails Disney feels the
pain but it's not as if the entire
economy goes into a
recession maybe that'll happen I don't
know but know I don't think that's a
connection it's that's Project Specific
risk same thing with an oil company you
decide you're going to explore for oil
somewhere if you don't find the oil it
affects you but it's not bringing the
entire it's that affects just the
company so whatever company you used to
work at your comfortable think about the
kinds of Investments they made that
affect just the
company let's move One Step Up the
Ladder obviously Disney plus is exposed
to competition specifically from n
Netflix but everybody and their brother
now is a streaming company
right and they're trying to take market
share away from you they're trying to
affect you and if they come up with
something much better than expected
that's going to affect you it's not that
you did something bad but they're doing
something extra special so one of the
markets that Disney plus and Invidia
fighting I'm sorry and Netflix are
fighting over is
India and they're struggling with what's
the best model let's say Netflix beats
Disney to comes up with a better
business model for India which doesn't
require as much local content and
actually makes money that's going to
affect Disney as a company it'll affect
Netflix as a company it affect one it'll
affect the companies in the street
screaming space which might be 8 10 15
companies with perhaps some satellite
compan but still a subset of companies
hang in there we've gone from RIS that
affects one company risk that affects
maybe 20 or 30
companies Disney's in the broadcasting
business with ABC and the broadcasting
business Still Remains regulated in
terms of what it can do let's say
there's a change in
regulation Elon decides that the
regulation on the broadcasting and he
decides to take a look at rewriting
regulation and let's say the regulation
gets
Rewritten will Disney be affected yes so
will every other company in the
broadcasting space we've gone from from
risk it affects one company to a few
companies to perhaps risk it affects an
entire Industry Group or maybe even a
sector let's keep
going the dollar has been on this
strengthening Bene last year the Dollar
strengthened by about 9% collectively
against Global currencies
right now I think the euro is at $1.03
to EUR it's the lowest I've
seen since 20 years ago if the dollar
strengthens and continues to strengthen
will it affect Disney as a
company why why Ravi why would it affect
disne as a
company because it gets revenues and
euros and and repes and now they have to
be converted so basically it will affect
in good ways and bad ways right the good
ways is it might make it's its it its
foreign earnings look much it much much
better but the bad way is fewer people
might come to the US to the theme parks
because now it's more expensive for a
Brazilian to fly to Disneyland because
the dollar is stronger we'll talk about
the net effect but clearly dollar
strengthening will affect is will it
affect other companies in the market
yeah in fact it might affect the the
subset of companies that
significant Global exposure which might
be what 20% 25% of the
companies you can play the same guy game
out with tariffs or whatever else as a
subset of companies but perhaps the
entire Market is not affected because
some companies will benefit some might
not but it's still risk that affects
more companies and let's move one final
step up the ladder talked about interest
rates changing right 1.51% of the start
of 2022 now it's at 4. 5 4.6% who knows
what'll be at the end of
2025 when interest rates go up will
Disney be
affected yeah so will every other
company in the market so will every
other investment in good ways and bad
ways we've gone from risk that effects
one company to risk that effects most
all
companies why does it matter if you put
all your money in Disney which of these
risks are you exposed to all of them but
if you make Disney one of 20 or 25
stocks in your portfolio there's a magic
that's going to happen risk that is
specific to the company is going to get
average out this is not a finance idea
it's a law of large numbers and
statistics for every company that does
worse than expected Disney does worse in
The Avengers movie maybe Netflix in your
portfolio does better than expected on
its India
investment diversification is not a
magical concept it's just the law of
large numbers you have lots of different
companies risk that affect one or a few
companies are going to get averaged out
but risk that affect most or all
companies can't get averaged out you
could hold the entire market and if
tomorrow interest rates went up to 6%
you're going to feel the pain no matter
how Diversified you are see the argument
for
diversification is this you can make it
on economic rounds you can make it on
stat you probably saw the statistical
derivation in your foundations class you
take a two asset portfolio and you can
see the standard it's just I mean it's
essentially taking the Law of large said
this is how it'll play out but the
bottom line is every investment now in
your portfolio is a smaller percentage
but more importantly the the kinds of
news you get in Investments you have
enough investments will start to average
if not on any given day and sometimes
when I read the Wall Street Journal I
first page I'm happy the third page I'm
because I have 40 stocks in my portfolio
and by the time I'm done I've gone in
this roller coaster right good news bad
news good news bad especially around
earning season right some companies beat
expectations if all of them are below
there is a message there saying this is
a macro thing you have to start worrying
about but to the extent that it's
company specific it's going to average
out so the argument for diversification
is both a common sense one and one that
basically makes you think about risk
differently so now the question is
what happens in the capital asset
pricing model where you assume that the
investor setting prices is Diversified I
know how many of you own shares and
companies but my guess is a quite a few
of you
do when you invest in a stock my guess
is you're investing buying a th000
shares maybe 10,000 shares if you're
feeling really
rich most of
us own relatively few shares
the investors whose risk who through
whose eyes you have to measure risk are
called the marginal investors saying
who's the marginal investor you're two
things you're looking for first margin
investors own a lot of shares you saying
how many shares are a lot of shares it
depends on the size of the company the
inv it's got to be immense amounts of
shares right hundreds of millions maybe
billions of dollars of shares and second
they trade those
shares so one of the first things you
ask is who is the marginal invest in the
company because they're the ones who are
going to set the terms for what kind of
risk will get measured in a risk and
return model and in financial Theory
every single risk and return model
starts with the assumption that the
marginal investor is a diversified
investor the capm doesn't assume that
we're all Diversified because most of us
are not in fact we know that the median
number of stocks in an individual
investors portfolio is you know what the
number is four to six stocks most of us
are our
Diversified but we don't set prices we
don't own enough shares as long as the
marginal investors is Diversified this
assumption go so one of the first places
to start when you look at your company
is who's the marginal investor in your
company so I'm going to start with some
very simplistic metrics you can get for
your company if it's publicly traded if
it's private business it's a very
different game we're going to talk about
what happens there you a publicly traded
company of shares out there people own
the shares you're looking for the
percentage of stock held by institutions
which you can find for your company and
the percentage of stock held by insiders
there's a legal definition of insiders
insiders include managers directors but
I also include people own more than 5%
of the shares so insiders and
institutions what do what can I glean
from this if the percentage of shares
held by institutions is
high no matter what the company is the
marginal investor in your company is an
Institutional Investor right
now if you have a company with high
institutional holding and high Insider
holding what kind of company would that
be we just looked at
one they come like Facebook High
institutional holding but you also have
Founders CEO owning shares there you can
argue it's still
institutional but you have this this
wild card what will the individual
running the company do but they have to
still obey the tenants of the market
because they have too much at that's why
Mark Zuckerberg reacted to the Met
metaverse Fiasco by stepping away from
it if your institutional Holdings are
low then you get into more dangerous
territory in terms of who the modu
investors whether they Diversified if
you have low institutional holding and
you have lots held by insiders it's
tough to tell because it depends on
whether those insiders are entirely
invested in the company or they have
Diversified portfolios of their own so
one of the Insiders happens to be an
activ investor let's say Carl I can he
also owns other stocks in his portfolio
he might still bring in a diversified
investor perspective even though he's an
Insider if it's low and held by a
wealthy individual investor you might
want to check out that wealthy
Investor's portfolio if they that person
allows you to check it out Paul Allen
for a while know he was co-founded
Microsoft with Bill Gates but he left he
didn't want to work at the company but
he took a substantial amount of his
wealth and he invested in an individual
company companies he owned the portal
and Trailblazers for a while but
essentially he was a diversified
investor a lot of family groups invest
family group money in companies they're
still
Diversified but if you have institutions
and insiders holding low then it might
be a small individual investor who's not
Diversified now we're on territory we're
assuming the investor the margin
investor is Diversified is going to be
difficult where would you put private
businesses on this you're entirely owned
by one person right the owner
and know how many of you know the owners
of Private Business they tend to be
Diversified people they can't afford to
be all their wealth is tied up in the
business we now at the extreme scenario
that you have a company where the
investor is completely undiversified
which means what none of the risk and
return models and finance are going to
work for you because they're all
premised that the marginal investor is
Diversified so I'm going to go back to a
page I showed you in the context of
where does the power lie but now I'm
asking a different question who are the
marginal investors in my company and I'm
going to move to Disney in
2013 remember I showed you know 2003
there were no individuals I think Roy
Disney was the only one then I showed
you
2009 was Steve Jobs had gone to the top
of the list
2013 it's you know Steve had passed on
lorine jobs was now the largest
shareholder but you got a new name on
the list George
Lucas how did George Lucas become a
large shareholder in
Disney Disney bought Star Wars or Lucas
Films remember they he buy just Star
Wars he bought Lucas Films which brought
all of the other
properties George Lucas became a large
shareholder too but neither Loren jobs
nor George Lucas is a marginal investor
why not they own a lot of shares but
what do they not do they don't trade
them you can track their Holdings it's
the same reason Mark Zuckerberg is not
the marginal investor in in Facebook he
owns a lot of shares but if you look at
his Holdings because he wants them to
keep control essentially he hardly ever
shares Larry Ellison is the largest
share in Oracle but he's not the marinal
investor so what does that leave you
with the rest of the list and who's on
the rest of the list the usual culprits
are they likely to be
Diversified
absolutely so if you put this list up
for your company most of your companies
not all of them most of your companies
going to look at the list and say I'm on
safe ground assuming the marginal
investor
is
Diversified in fact when I started
looking at the rest of my companies I'll
give you different degrees of assurance
I felt about this so if I when I looked
at deut Val too and B first looked at
individuals and institutions and you can
see that you know the institutional
holding in deutche is pretty high so I
think deutche is the marginal investors
is Diversified but it's much lower for
both Val and
Motors so I was a little concerned there
but then you look at the Holdings that
the and mod is the reason you have a
lower institutional holding is the F the
family still controls through all these
other companies so I took a look at what
their Holdings have been over time and
it was pretty stable what does that tell
me they're not trading they're holding
these shares because a legacy Holdings
so even though TARTA Motors the
institutional holding might be only 25%
I'm sorry 44% you're essentially going
to be okay because those institutions
are the ones who I think they accounted
for 80% of the trading in t Motor stock
so you can look at the percentage held
by institutions and even if it's low if
they're accounting for the bulk of the
trading modal investor in your company's
diversify and that's good news for you
because it means you can use beta or
betas or whatever other risk and return
models in
finance but if if individuals are the
bulk of the trading then I think we
might have to think about how we and
we'll deal with private businesses and
maybe extend that approach to your
company
CU your company is one of those
companies where the mod investor is not
Diversified they're not Diversified the
way they think about risk
changes so does anybody have an issue
with the argument that
diversification reduces or even
eliminates company specific risk because
that's kind of a slam down we can debate
whether you want to diversify or not
that's going to be the weekly puzzle for
this week is there are people
high-profile people out there who argue
that concentration
is better than
diversification that you should own five
or 10 Big oldtime Value investors now
argue that you should own five and they
use this word conviction right if you
have conviction why would you need to
own 40 stocks why can't you just own the
five best stocks in the market and I'm
going to let you work that through
because it's not something I'm going to
impose on you I want to think about the
arguments because clearly you're giving
up something right you're giving up the
diversification what are you gaining in
return and I think there might be cases
where you might
concentrate I don't have that degree of
conviction but others
might but let's move to the third step
diversification is good the question is
why do we stop diversifying and this
might answer your concentration argument
I I gave away how many stocks I own 40
stocks right you know how many publicly
traded stocks are in the market what
48,000 so I'm going to ask you a
question why you think I stopped at 40
give me the cruel answer
first I don't the cruel answer is you
don't have enough money yeah I agree I
don't have billions to throw around so
one reason we stop is we're not we're
not worth 40 billion 80 billion or 100
billion so what's the other and I think
you're one is you know if I own more
than that I've got to you know not just
overview this transactions cost in
getting them and then out to monitoring
cost in making sure they're there
there's a cost that we put
in and there's a third reason at a
certain point the benefits of
verification but you get a c but they're
always positive so you got to give me
something so that's what we're bringing
in as the other side because the
benefits are there when you add the
15,000 stock it's is far smaller than
the 5,000 but it's still not less than
zero right it's still positive so but
why does a mutual fund that has billions
of dollars stop you know it doesn't so
it can deal with the transactions caus
the monitoring so why why does it
stop that's part of the cost issue right
so let's time is always convertible into
cost why do mutual
funds well I can still diversify me to
risk we talk about more sensible if if
you believe in the world where
diversification is good there are ways
in which I can bring in Risk preferences
without stopping at a certain point
what's the sales pitch if you're an
active investor what do you tell
investors you can
do that you can pick the best stocks
right so you know the third reason you
stop because you think you can pick the
best
stocks here's what the capm assumes we
can come back and deal with those
assumptions first it assumes no
transactions cost all the costs we
talked about they're gone and second it
assumes no private information which is
a euphemism for you can't pick
stocks so let's go let's stay in the APM
Universe no transactions costs no
private information you can't pick good
stocks so when would you stop
diversifying the 40th stock clearly you
can keep going 41st you run through
48,000 you're not quite done you might
buy traded Bonds in fact you won't stop
till you have a small piece of every
single traded asset in the market it's a
logical endgame right I know it's based
on completely unrealistic assumption no
transactions cost and you can't pick
stock but we're all going to end up with
a portfolio that includes every single
traded asset in the market what should
we call this portfolio oh let's be
really creative and call it the market
portfolio you know the market portfolio
is it's a gigantic Index
Fund which owns every we're actually
close to creating those right Vanguard
is trying to create total market index
funds so let's say you have this
gigantic Index Fund that's what every
one of us will invest in somebody
brought up there brought risk
preferences now he say how in this
world would we deal with the fact that
we have different risk preferences let's
say how much do you like to take a lot
of risk very little risk give me a risk
preference moderate risk so let's say
for you I I would take half your money
and put it into this gigantic index fund
and how do I buffer the fact that you
don't want to take a lot of risk I put
the rest into something riskless
tbu I moved on to Derek I'm going to
impose risk preference on you even
though it might not be right let's say
Derek likes to take more risk than you
I'll put 80% or even 100% of a money in
the index fund and less into Tes Ravi
though wants to take even more risk he's
say how do you get Beyond 100% you know
how I get Ravi in this world he I borrow
money and I buy 150% of his wealth and
put in an index fund if you live in the
capm world we all buy the same Index
Fund what's going to be different is how
much money we put in the fund and how
much we put in the riskless asset or
borrow at the riskless
asset it's a logical end game which
means all of us are going to end up
owning the same big index fund and it
changes the way you think about risk
right because then the risk of an
investment becomes the risk it adds to
this gigantic Market
portfolio we're almost home if we can
somehow measure that risk we essentially
have the riskiness of a stock and the
way we measure is again we stay in the
statistical space when I have a
portfolio and I'm looking at its
variance and I want to say how much does
that additional investment add to my
portfolio I measured What's called the
co-variance which is how does it move
with the rest of the stuff in my
portfolio I'll give you the intuition if
you add something that doesn't move at
all with the rest of your portfolio
effectively is adding no risk you won't
even notice it being there if it add If
It Moves a lot with your portfolio
you'll actually increase the risk by the
co-variance and if it moves in the
opposite direction as your portfolio
what is adding it going to do it's going
to reduce the risk in your portfolio
everything rides on this co-variance how
does your stock move with the market
portfolio so I could stop that because
we've almost got the capm and I could
give you the co-variance of IBM with the
market portfolio let's say I told you it
was 35% what's the problem with that
number if I told you
35% you have no idea whether it's high
low average right it's basically a
number so it'd be nice if I could
standardize the number so here's the
last step I take that covariance of
every stock with the market and I divide
the covariance by the variance of the
entire
Market if you take a look at the
statistical definition of a beta that's
what it is we've effectively standardize
the co-variance but we're still in the
space of measuring risk to a market
portfolio
so that's it we we've got the cap app so
I'll leave you with one final point
which is does the model have proms why
does it have proms first does it make
unrealistic
assumptions absolutely we live in a mean
variance World starting with that
assumption that we can you know that
that we can borrow and lend at the risk
free rate that's another assumption no
transactions
cost but I started as an econ student
and I very quickly gave because I
discovered in economics you have a
choice you can either make realistic
assumptions and end up with models that
nobody can use or unrealistic
assumptions and end up with pragma
models that can be used I'll take the
latter over the former it's true we make
unrealistic assumptions but we end up
with a useable model
second you be told the model doesn't
work you know the getting the parameters
you could get them wrong the you know
you could get the beta wrong the risk
premium wrong this is the cowards
argument against the cap my response is
you think that's all I got wrong you
should see my earnings number the cash
flow numbers you're going to get them
all wrong why because you're trying to
forecast the future if your argument for
a model is I will not use it until the
parameters are perfect you'll never find
a usable model but the third one is the
one that I think is going to create the
most problems and we're going to start
the next class with it it doesn't work
that well how do we know when you test
it out against the pass if it's a
perfect RK and return model to explain
difference in returns I'll start with
what researchers have found on the capm
and then talk about what the alternative